One model is the so-called
Passthrough Model.
The way the pass through model
works is that the VMM level driver
is responsible for configuring
the access permissions for device.
For instance, it will allow a Guest VM
to have access to the memory where
the control registers for
the device are.
There are clearly benefits to this
approach, one is for instance,
that the guest VM has exclusive
access to a particular device.
It's the only one that can manipulate
its state, it can control it and
it's the only one that will use it.
Also, the VM's accesses to the device
completely bypass the hypervisor, so
there are direct accesses to the device.
This model is also called
the VMM bypass model.
Now clearly, once we start providing
VMs with exclusive access,
figuring out a way to share
devices will become difficult.
Well, basically have to
continuously reassign,
which particular VM it can access
a particular device over time.
But the sharing will not happen
simultaneously, concurrently.
That in some cases is,
is really not doable,
because of the limitations
of the device.
In other cases, it can be done, but it
will be very high overhead operations.
So, in practice really device sharing
with this model is not feasible.
Now because the hypervisor is
completely out of the way,
it means that the Guest VM and the
Device Driver that's in the Guest VM,
directly operates and
controls the particular physical device.
So that means that when we're launching
this Guest VM, there better be a device
of the exact same type as expected by
the Guest OS on the physical machine.
In some cases, maybe in the server space
that's not as critical of a requirement
just because there are fewer types of
devices that are commonly present there.
But in other environments, this is
really not a practical constraint.
Remember, we're not talking about
the fact that there needs to be
a network interface, or
a disk device or hard disk device.
We're talking about the exact same,
particular type of network card or
hard disk drive that
the Guest VM expects
depending on the device
drivers that it has.
Also, we mentioned that one of
the benefits of virtualization is that
the Guest VM started decouples
from the physical hardware.
And therefore, we can migrate them
easily to other nodes in the system.
Well, this pass through really
breaks that decoupling,
because it directly
binds a device to a VM.
This makes migration
difficult in particular,
because there may be some
device specific state and
potentially even device resident state
that would also need to be copied and
migrated and then properly configured
at the destination mount and then
basically that turns VM migration not in
a hyperviser and VM specific operation.
But it needs to be implemented in a way
that knows how to deal with the device
specifics of all of the particular
devices that are of interest.